was there anyone it from the resident
security team in the house when you
arrived on
march 8th 2015.
no okay and the resident security team
is it your understanding that they were
there that they were kind of guarding
the house
they would have been in the grounds but
the substantial grounds
real substantial ground
they would have hit the ground somewhere
but they didn't but they didn't go into
the house on on march 8th correct
i don't know i never seen them in the
house okay
and so when you arrived at the house and
and went and went in was it just
mr depp and amber heard
just mr that number okay and before
maybe someone else here i never visibly
seen anyone else i wasn't there long
enough to chat
to anybody and when you arrived at the
house you could you could hear a ruckus
correct
yes well yes i could hear enough yeah
yeah i could hear definitely hear
something through the the the door here
but you said the door was so thick you
couldn't hear the actual words that were
being said is that right
no just
a shouting
and then you saw then you went in the
house and saw mr depp in the foyer
correct
yes correct and mr depp was trying to
urinate in the four year wasn't he
no
mr mr depp had his penis out of his
objection
[Music]
next question and you were trying to get
mr depp out of the house correct
correct i'll try to get mr deadpool
and mr depp was refusing to leave the
house was he not
not so much refused he just wanted two
minutes to save peace you took mr depp's
arm to try to move him out but he broke
away isn't that right
yes okay
i mean so he was strong enough to break
away from your grip correct
no
so
you had his arm and he broke away though
correct
no
isn't that what you just said
no i let him go you let go yes but it
wasn't easy it wasn't he's going to drag
him
so mr depp's your boss you'll do what mr
deb wants correct
no
it's not easy to get mr deb out of the
house correct
not easy